an eye for an eye in Senegal's wall of
language
it is a rallying call made by opposition
leader Usman Sanko to his supporters
Soko says he's being held against his
will at his residence we try to visit
him but police won't allow us to film or
let us in from his home he sends this
message
I call for a national surge a national
resistance movement in accordance with
our constitution to face makisal foreign
the government says it's maintaining law
in order days ahead of a verdict in a
trial where sonko is accused of rape
if found guilty he will not be able to
run in the February 2024 presidential
elections we are demonstrating because
this is an attempt to eliminate our
candidate we are protesting for
democracy in Senegal we are
demonstrating against the restrictions
on individual and Collective liberties
demonstrators are targeting homes of
ministers foreign-owned supermarkets and
petrol stations demonstrators are
intentionally targeting petrol station
it's become a symbol since the discovery
of oil and gas because whoever becomes
president in February 2024 will be in
charge of this enormous resource that's
promising billions of dollars in Revenue
present cell won't say if he will
attempt to run for a third term critics
argue that that would be
unconstitutional and this is
exacerbating political tensions
the violence the fighting and political
field is almost in ruins it feels like
the tensions are rising and escalating
and it seems that the oil and gas is
becoming a curse for Senegal
the petrol
Senegal Civil Society denounce both the
government and the political opposition
for the violence and instability with
their fight over power spilling on the
streets ahead of a presidential election
still eight months away Nicholas Hawk Al
Jazeera Dakar